all right crystal and jason
where you guys from originally
i was born and raised in ghana beach
i was born in torrance so both south
south bay south yeah suburbs south of
l.a yeah and tell me about how you guys
grew up crystal you had your mom and dad
my parents got divorced when i was
five
and then
i lived with
my mom in hawthorne um for most of the
week when i saw my dad every other
weekend
um i guess when i was a kid
um
yeah
i don't know
how would you describe your childhood
um my mom was a
was a
tweaker i guess and
um so like when me and my sister were
with my mom um
we kind of like got to experience like
both sides i think she's like my mom
like literally did drugs all the time
then when we go visit my dad like he
lived in manhattan beach and like a nice
house and like there was always food and
stuff but
um
yeah
my parents liked to
argue a lot and my mom always had like
different
friends over and
i don't know
any any crazy things that went on your
childhood any of you something like that
um
not
um
[Music]
if you're not comfortable talking about
it
jason uh what was you had mom and dad
growing up
yeah uh my dad died when i was seven um
and he went to jail like right after i
was born and then got out in like
87 or something like that so we've been
doing like seven years and then uh he
ain't getting killed by torrance pg
that was that right yeah i shot around
hanzo
um
i saw it but like blanked it out most of
my life i guess and
you saw your dad get killed yeah but
like they like sent me like therapy and
[ __ ] so like i ended up like blanking it
out
and then like
like years later it kind of came like
kind of like finally came to like
fruition in my brain or whatever and
like seeing it
like somebody like i blanked it out i
guess so my mom actually lied to me
about it my mom told me like even though
i saw it with him he got hit by a car
and when i actually found out about it
was at like a high school party someone
that like
had grew up um someone's like that was
that i went to high school with
his stepdad was like
uh him and my dad were like mortal
enemies or some [ __ ] you know and like
he's only actually said something like
kind of out of spite told me like uh you
know some [ __ ] and that's how i came to
find out about it and then yeah after
that but yeah after my dad i mean i was
waiting for my mom but like same thing
my mom was like a drug addict you know
sold drugs
[ __ ] like that wow
similar stories but different types of
dads yeah yeah
and uh
we could have met each other but i'm
like 10 years younger than him
so if we did i think he wouldn't like
recognizing or remember anything
but our mom is like really kind of like
the same group of people right
you guys both graduated high school i
graduated in 98. i didn't um i
i ended up getting sent away to like
boarding schools and stuff when i was um
15
from times 15 until i was 18 when i got
out i just i didn't finish college and
then i went and got my ged
um
back in 2010
[Music]
and drug use started for you guys at
what age
um on an everyday basis like crystal
like
13 probably 14
and
like crystal coke and
i started smelling when i was like 11 12
um but like coke
speed
uh
crack here and there a little bit and
then but like uh
opiates like heroin [ __ ] like that and
pills like probably like 16 17.
what are you using now
uh heroin fentanyl and crystal
yeah crystal is that what you're using
as well yeah
and i
started when i was probably
13 and then um
i got sent away to boarding school in
utah when i was 15 to
stop using that when i got out
i started using again and then i started
using
heroin i think when i was 20.
i'm third i'm 30 now so
do you feel like the
environment that you guys grew up around
like your moms that were both addicts
kind of
left the door open for you guys to do
the same a little bit you know i mean
everyone makes certain decisions you
know i mean yeah but you were you but it
was around the house yeah you saw it at
least in your family
yeah
um
i think so
i my mom didn't really try to like hire
the fact that she was
using drugs and
i don't think she did it like to
try to like set me up for failure but
you know i just i think that at the time
she had made me thought that like it was
the right answer and helping her in some
sense maybe that's where she was
entertaining i don't know but she didn't
really hide the fact that she was using
yeah
so you guys are living aware now
uh
yeah here and there
hotels um when we can afford it
and then every once in a while like a
couple times we got a spot like a nice
tent you know like a 10-12 maintain
we've kept it for like
a good amount of time like three four
months you know
um and then uh
like like we lost our last hit because
it's some weird-ass [ __ ] uh
like we uh
we were out like you know trying to make
money and [ __ ] and
we came back to our spot and there was
this black dude that was there was all
strummed out and just decided he was
gonna take over our spot and take all of
our [ __ ]
and when she went back to her spot
before me
and uh like she came running up to me
saying hey you see that guy in her
channel like no what are you talking
about
and uh
she i was like telling this guy and he
was walking up he's like yeah that's all
my [ __ ] you gotta get the hell out we
ended up going back and forth in it
and he ended up busting me in the face
with a baseball bat
and uh
i was like damned and knocked out and he
threatened he said he was gonna for fun
he was gonna rape her and break her jaw
and i chased after him and i got a hold
of my hammer and i split the back of his
head open with the hammer he didn't fall
down or anything i didn't didn't even
faze him yeah i feel so streamed out i
didn't even think i thought i'd miss
maybe or something like
i missed and then i turned around a bit
my friend our friend finally showed up
with like a machete and stephanie that
he finally took off i'm not saying we
saw like the back of his head yeah and
uh yeah lately you see the scar on my
face right here yeah some dude i came
out of a um
the goodwill on uh
that sixth street right
yeah
burlington or whatever right there
some black guys counting her in the face
somebody
was really like disrespectful to me so i
stopped to like say something to him and
he like punched me in the face like that
it's like i remember i was supposed to i
saw him and i dropped him when he
knocked him and i when i went to him
again he pulled a [ __ ] big-ass knife
and he slashed me like right here he
went from my neck but i kind of like he
said he didn't want to go to the
hospital i was like i can see her teeth
and he had 82 stitches
want to pick up right now and i was like
i felt like something like flapper here
like this i'm like oh [ __ ] we're going
to go to the hospital i can see my teeth
i was like really
wow and then
this happened like right in front of the
police station
the black dude ended up calling the cops
i mean they didn't show up or anything
but he called the cops afterwards
we assaulted him or something i don't
know even living on skid row uh no it
was actually by macarthur parker yeah
i know on sixth street
same thing i think the cops even like
drove by
actually yeah they caused to drive by
and they were like don't jaywalk and i
was like are you kidding that's what
they said to us we were like i was like
stumbling across the street to the
hospital and they actually have the
window don't jaywalk i was like do you
know i see i'm like pouring blood on my
face
and do you have either of you have kids
yeah i have a uh 11 year old son i
haven't seen since i i finished a prison
term back in 2017 i saw him and that's
what i saw was 2015 um and i finished
president trump in 2017 and my ex-wife
is kind of
kevin because of like drugs and you know
the environment that create the jokes
for you i got a restraining order yeah
um i have
i have a daughter um and they have a son
my daughter lives in new mexico with her
dad and she's
11 and then i have a
reason to be
gonna be three this year i have a son
um who
um
got adopted by his foster family in
arizona
who's gonna be 30 this year oh he's
gonna be three three okay
something doesn't make sense no yeah
he's be three
i
i it's a long story but um he's in
arizona
my
mom and my grandma had him and then they
yeah
my grandma has a cancer and they found
out i guess they signed him over to cps
so
um they still see him and stuff so
he's doing okay
what emotions do you guys deal with
living like this this lifestyle
do you get depressed or
i think we have a lot of time like to
really sit and like think about things
like that i think that's why like
when you do drugs at least it gives us
something else to do and focus on maybe
right so you don't have to feel yeah
it's like an everyday you know hustle
and struggles you call it like getting
money getting like
getting money
going to pick up you know uh
keeping me on me i got keeping her safe
you know and
it's like yeah and it's not the hardest
thing to do in the world but it's you
know fifteen years late at night you
know and sometimes we don't like right
now we don't have a tent or anything
it's like if i haven't hustle up enough
money to like give us a hotel room like
it's you know
i gotta stay up like if one of us falls
asleep they don't have to stay awake
kind of because we both fall asleep you
wake up with your goddamn shoes gone
sometimes and [ __ ] you know does just
being a couple make it harder or easier
i said yeah it makes it easier because i
know when i before you met down here how
long have you been in together uh about
a year and a half well when i met him my
ex was in jail and i had been out here
by myself for
quite a few months actually
um
that was
it's a lot harder by yourself really
sure like if you're especially for a
female i would think yeah
a lot harder
do we
you've mentioned a little bit about your
family do you still have contact with
your families
um my mom and my grandma
um
yeah i
i don't really talk to them and
just she's like
i'm like using drugs and i know my
grandma's like stressed out and i don't
always have a phone
um but my dad i haven't talked to him in
a few years
actually
and
my
my sisters um
my sisters
actually sent me a message
last time i checked my facebook my
younger sister sent me a message
wondering like what was going on i guess
since i didn't answer she was i'm not a
little kid anymore
she wanted to i just i i haven't had a
phone you know and jason do you still
yeah i don't know hardly ever like uh
his mom had somebody tell him that he
would hear her friend tom that she died
and like faked a death certificate yeah
she's like completely fake like sit next
to like dead and like she said can't she
i mean i want to really get along but
like she's a tough old [ __ ]
she's had cancer three or four times and
beat it every time wow
and um she's just you know he thought
she was dead i thought she was dead for
like six or seven months
and i called it one of my friends to i
don't remember what the hell i was
calling him for but i said something to
him about it and he's like how are you
talking about your mom's not dead
and then he's like she still has cancer
right because i just had lunch with her
yesterday
yesterday before i was like
the [ __ ] are you talking about
i was like somebody called up and like i
called the person that told me she was
dead no answer no answer no answer
you know and uh i mean mom just didn't
really get along you know i mean like we
just we argued constantly and [ __ ] like
vote like to like i guess what you call
it something personalities like we're
always button heads yeah
so is is there a chance you guys might
get pregnant and have a kid
not right now
maybe too hard
maybe sometimes
are you doing something to prevent that
yeah are you
i mean
no it's not something i really think
about
okay
what are you afraid of what do you what
do you worry about
um
me right now and the only thing i don't
be afraid of is like losing her
say anything like
um i guess don't think it's scary is he
like overdosed one time
and uh like turned blue and stuff out to
give him more hair
yeah i should tell him about it i
actually remember that like
she like she's actually narcan me a few
times and the times before i thought i
didn't need to be narcan because i don't
you probably don't know anything about
but like being narcan just son of a
[ __ ]
that's the worst feeling ever
like one for a person that's like that
drugs wants to get high like it
completely sobers you the [ __ ] up
like a hundred percent like yeah and you
can't get high outside everything
becomes really long
for about probably a day and a half like
the as like opiate blockers and all that
[ __ ]
and then it like just makes you really
flips your whole system upside down like
everything doesn't seem real everything
seems surreal around you like everything
kind of seems staged really sick and you
get really and uh
but the the three times that you know
our camera before that like i think i
was just like really really high he
hadn't turned blue but this time like i
turned but i remember like her like i
remember my chest like seizing i
remember my heart like stopping like i
could feel it like in my like i could
feel my chest like tighten up and i
remember her on the top of me like
banging me in the face like
don't do this you son of a [ __ ] and i
remember like everything's just going
blind
and the next thing i remember is my
balls being like frozen ice cold and i
woke up and she had like five pounds of
ice down my pants and i was like
and i was like what do you have to do to
me [ __ ]
do you guys have hopes of uh getting
your lives together getting clean all
that yeah yeah we've talked about like
what are the better ways of doing it
like
i have an aunt
that's about the only family member that
i get along with left my whole family
she's out in vegas and then her her
husband do like really well for himself
like he actually there's a restaurant
called
texas lucy's
um
there's one in
torrance i know i wanted to make it a
few other him and his brother are the
ones that started that china restaurant
and so
um like and then she has her own company
now they do really well and she has an
aunt that's like uber uber rich like
really really rich like she has a hand
that's worth like hundreds of millions
nobody got it yeah we've been talking
about going into the bathroom like
finally and it's not like sober but like
it's like definitely it gives you
something else i have reservations
because i got her off methadone when i
first got together and like three
methadone is even worse than the goddamn
heroin you know i think he's a trade-off
you do methadone you're not having to
worry about like making money and
picking up and
getting high all day like you go once
and you take your destiny and do
whatever you want
throughout the rest of the day
it's it's not like you're only focused
you're only going to survive
like
that's the way i say you get sick when
you come off of it but it's like kind of
like a trade-off right
because you either spend your whole life
like trying to get drugs you know or
you can take methadone and you can like
live your life a little bit more but i
know you're gonna get sick when you come
off of it
either way
what do you what would you say is the
most important thing in your lives
right now her like each other my dog
yeah so i actually got her this is the
second dog i actually you know he found
us
but about
about six months ago i got her a dog and
paid for it it was a
half pit bull half german shepherd she
liked to try to kill me though
the love hate relationship the dog like
loved her but hated her like
they like fall behind she bit the crap
out of her a couple times
but someone actually stole the dog
like i had them tied up right outside
our tent and someone just cut the leash
and took him
sucked everybody is
different
all right well crystal and jason thank
you so much for sharing your stories
yeah i wish you guys the best of luck
out there thank you thank you very much
you